hi I'm Wendy Williams hunter my  organization the hunter Foundation  recently launched a nationwide hotline  to offer treatment resources for you if  you are a drug addict or substance  abuser one eight eight eight five hunter  the calls are being answered by  specially trained certified recovery  coaches they're very smart  they conduct screenings to determine  your needs the substance abuse will be  taken care of we will provide you with  referrals for long or short-term  treatment at facilities all around the  world detox rehab sober living and  outpatient centers everywhere nationwide  if you're an addict or a substance  abuser don't be ashamed help us here for  you or a family member or a loved one  call don't be ashamed there is hope I'm  living proof go to WWNT - foundation org  for more information  [Music]